salon eyes and wrote and
suddenly attacking him incomprehensibly and he may have
immediately knocked out the window
when this happened and you were frightened
probably not really not because I
felt it didn’t hurt me
where to run to deviated from this
didn’t do anything else
to get out of there
everything is
fine
linger no more  there won’t be a
hayloft in a hurry to just get behind the bed and I
went to the toilet to
wash my bathtub and I’m in the same place
and the floors came,
I look here the lights converge with the
bulbs I turn on I’m alive I’m
killing get me out of the entrance they came in the door
broke down and pulled out I gave  I didn’t understand three
four explosions and how I was already in the
bathroom before the fourth one, the
gold filled me up with the fourth explosion
[music]